c'est supporter instants de son nouveau
prénom tom non plus comme un les tomes
mulcair
c'est le début de la campagne électorale
et alors comment se les promesses les
conservateurs de stephen harper veulent
imposer un péage nouveau sur le pont
champlain pour le npd
il n'en est pas question c'est sur ce
même mont royal
il y a huit ans que thomas mulcair a
annoncé sa conversion one [ __ ] fédéral lui
qui avait toujours été un libéral
provincial à l'époque de toute son
histoire
le npd n'avait fait lire qu'un seul
député au québec
le geste de thomas mulcair apparaissait
pour tous comme un suicide politique
sauf pour dire que c'était facile pour
moi de conclure que le parti
néo-démocrate représenter ces mêmes
valeurs que je crois partagée avec
beaucoup de canadiens contre toute
attente thomas mulcair s'est fait élire
dans outremont en 2011 le phénomène jack
layton au québec a eu l'effet de la lune
sur les marées et a créé une grande
vague 59 députés élus au npd
nous revoici donc en 2013 à la ligne de
départ ils sont là ces inconnus de
l'époque qui maintenant ont été député
pendant quatre ans la plupart se
présente à nouveau être candidat du npd
au québec c'est devenu un poste convoité
au moins trois députés npd sont fait
battre lors de leur assemblée
d'investiture et pour la prochaine
assemblée d'investiture dans
notre-dame-de-grâce
il y a huit candidats j'ai tellement
hâte que les progressistes du reste du
canada plus se joindre aux progressistes
du québec pour former le premier
gouvernement social démocrate npd dans
l'histoire du canada le npd veut nouveau
profité d'une vague au québec
nous on est non seulement
l'espoir de maintenir nos sièges les
sièges qu'on a gagné lors de la vague en
démêlant mais aussi d'aller chercher des
nouveaux sièges des vagues au québec il
y en a eu plusieurs
en 80 les libéraux ont fait élire 74
députés en 84 les conservateurs en ont
fait élire 58 et en 93 les bloquistes en
ont fait élire 54 et d'expérience tous
ces partis vous diront qu'après la vague
via leur sac
et quand ici maxence bilodeau
radio-canada montvert